I have some stunning tweets for you today
of Donald Trump actually blaming the guy in
the White House for protests happening around
our country.
Now, of course, the guy in the White House
when Trump was doing this was named Barack
Obama.
And Trump will never actually take responsibility
when it's him.
But it is another example of just the blistering
hypocrisy.
So back in 2014, there were protests in the
United States over the killing of black teenager
Michael Brown.
Donald Trump tweeted just a treasure trove
of attacks on Barack Obama for those protests,
including, quote, Our country is totally fractured.
And with our weak leadership in Washington,
you can expect Ferguson type riots and looting
in other places.
Trump also tweeting, and this one is extra
special.
Can you imagine what Putin and all of our
friends and enemies throughout the world are
saying about the U.S. as they watch the Ferguson
riot?
Well, imagine what they're saying now as we
have a level of unrest that makes what happened
around Ferguson look like child's play.
While Donald Trump's suggestion is bringing
the military to repress protests even more
aggressively.
What are they saying right now?
Well, we know what they're saying.
And we've heard from a number of those leaders,
including Canada's Justin Trudeau.
And they're horrified.
Another Trump tweet quote, As China and the
rest of the world continue to rip off the
U.S. economically, they laugh at us and our
president over the riots in Ferguson again.
What are they doing right now?
Now, of course, this time around when the
civil unrest is orders of magnitude bigger
than what we had in 2014.
It's combined with a 100 year pandemic.
Suddenly, none of it has anything to do with
Donald Trump.
It's everybody else's fault in this case.
Now, I told you yesterday that Donald Trump's
strategy has ironically been si CCP just a
coincidence that those are the initials CCP.
And what this means is confused about what's
actually happening in our country.
That's step one.
Number two, conflate and Trump has been conflating.
And so as Kaili, McEnany and other Trump lists
can conflate protesters, looters, rioters
and insiders criticize.
And this means pass the buck, pass the blame
to governors, to Democrats, to protesters,
to whoever else Trump can blame.
And then lastly, the P and C CCP is to pander,
pander to his Trump's base, much of which
loves authoritarianism.
And that, you know, we're going to have a
voicemail later on about the hypocrisy.
But, you know, all of these people who claim
to support Trump and who are owning guns because
they fear a tyrannical government will be
swept in and they will need their rifles to
defend themselves.
They are saying very little about the deployment
of state National Guards, about Donald Trump's
threat to deploy federal military assets to
states, in contrast, or in opposition to what
it is that governors are asking for.
And the really sad and tragic thing about
this approach is that many of his followers
have fallen for the idea that anything good
that happens is thanks to Trump and anything
bad that happens is somebody else's fault.
If you can blame Obama, that's great.
You can blame Democrats who can blame China.
You can blame the so-called fake news media.
That's all great.
So what we need right now, what we lack is
leadership, empathy, understanding and a really
steady hand.
At times like these, Trump can't lead.
Trump has no empathy.
Trump doesn't understand so many things.
And he has the opposite of a steady hand.
He has a completely erratic hand.
Trump is telling cops, don't be too nice.
Trump is telling governors you guys are jerks.
Trump is calling the protesters thugs.
Trump is conflating and and protesters.
And I did want to say one or the other thing
about the blaming of governors.
Notice that it is now a regular for Donald
Trump.
On Corona virus, when it became impossible
to defend his failed testing protocol, he
said, you know, really testing is up to the
governors.
In the end, they've got to figure out how
to test enough people for corona virus.
It's the same thing now.
He is saying it's the weak governors who aren't
being tough enough.
With the protesters blaming weak governors
from the White House and on Twitter is like
an arsonist blaming firefighters for not putting
out a fire that they started.
It makes absolutely no sense.
We are dealing with protests over police brutality
and Trump's big idea.
After a weekend of silence is to say, hey,
let's be more brutal with the protesters.
And then he blames governors for not doing
so.
It's all backwards.
My friends, it's all complete.
And utterly backwards.
And it's why we have
to
end it in November.